oh yeah good to see he'll say very good
[Music]
what experience has shaped you the most
when I reenacted the mutiny on the
bounty from 1789 we said 4,000 miles
from Tonga to Timor in a 23-foot
open and wooden boat we stuck exactly to
the regime of 350 calories a day going
from island to island
it took us 60 days I lost 4 stone and
initially when the project came up you
know I fought to myself but listen now
how hard can it be
you know it's give me a boat and some
men and I'll get the job done especially
being the captain and sort of treading
in Captains Bligh shoes the proudest
moment of that was we ran out of water 3
days towards the end we didn't collect
enough water some of it got contaminated
so we couldn't drink it and to the point
where people were passing out and
fainting and the whole crew at this
stage were like no with three days away
we're willing to suffer long term sort
of health issues to get the job done
and the moment they said that that's
when I as captain took over I said no
enough is enough
you know I'm not willing to have that on
my hands on that theme I actually took
three walking wounded boys yeah well
yeah well I took them first of all down
to the South Pole and then we took them
up to the North Pole so they did is
before Harry did it we were sore the
guinea pigs so it's very very you Anna
yes they weren't novices but I felt a
huge pressure and similar to you and you
the captain you know it's a very
different thing to as the captain so you
probably had a lot of sleepless nights
because you've all their
responsibilities and I found the same
whilst I think I can look after myself
in these and
it's a very different thing when you're
looking after someone else and they're
out of their comfort zone and you know
they're struggling with an injury and
things like that right did you have a
mentor quite a proud person I like to
think that I can do everything by myself
and I've always learned the hard way and
I don't regret that that's not always
the right thing to do because sometimes
my failures were catastrophic but I had
to pick myself back up from them and the
only person I could blame ultimately was
myself oh you went into the army very
young team yeah what about the PTI's and
I had a quite difficult army career
there's a lot of conflict of interest
there again you know me thinking that I
could take on the world by myself when I
left the army and we joined the Marines
after there was one guy that I'm I done
two tours of Afghanistan with he was an
officer and I always saw shun the
officers you know it's all about the
lads and the officers were a bit of a
different breed but he really sort of
brought me out of my shell he was a very
capable officer that led from the front
and I found myself with him a lot of
time going into combat with him you know
get off the helicopter straight into
into the compound straight into the the
area of conflict and it be just him and
me he did bring out a certain self
belief in myself every now and then you
do need to that little bit of pointing
in the right direction how about you
well I went to just the regular school
and they had the Duke of Edinburgh Award
oh and my PE master he took 40 boys and
put us in an army tent yeah no sleeping
bags or anything yeah we were kicked out
onto the Brecon Beacons so Audrey 13 oh
yeah but you know and it was scary
actually because first time I've been
away from home first time you share a
tent so that really started you know
and that pee master I looked up to him
and he I felt he was very much like a
father figure when I climbed Everest for
the first time in 93 I choked one of the
ice screws down and when I got home I
knitted a lot of years later I went
around I said there you go oh and I've
got there without you just to thank him
because without his input at a very
early age I would never have seen that
what has been the hardest moment of your
life don't leave going back to that one
of those big expeditions he was a solo
trip up to the North Pole yeah there was
a storm he came in and I was on this
little tent for seven days and that was
before GPS fees and there would be no
rescue there at that time of year and I
thought Christ you know I've really
messed up here thank goodness I've been
lucky and yourself hardest moment would
be going to prison when I left for the
military I got into a violent
altercation and ended up serving time
behind bars and the reason why it was
the hardest time is because it's so
shameful you know a family I had a wife
I was always used to providing for them
even when I was away
whether it be on tour of duty or
whatever it may be I was away providing
you know earning a living putting food
on the table and I went from being the
provider to being a burden on my family
you know spending time away not
providing not being the role model and
the man I should have been I suppose
when you're honest with yourself to a
point where you're ripping yourself to
shreds because of such a failure it
makes you realize what you need to do
when I look at Everest when I look at
selection when I look at the mutiny on
the bounty when I look at all my great
achievements which you know some people
say oh uh be lucky just to have one of
those I'm like but you don't realize all
the failures I've done to get to those
achievements you know all the knock-back
all the setbacks you know failed so much
more in life than I have achieved but
all these failures have led up to these
big achievements because that dogged
determination
that she will that passion that
determination and also just knowing
yourself and realizing where your
capabilities are where your limitations
are and just pushing them further and
further so I would always say you know
your great success will come from
failure have you ever witnessed someone
die yeah I've had a couple friends on
expeditions not come through okay and
the same yeah phew I'm quite used to
death actually
my father passed away and I was five
years old I went into the bedroom when
he was there when the police for this
got a good look at him so that sort of
opened my eyes up to it and then in the
military you know more powers and I
could want to imagine
yeah I'm not deaf doesn't really bother
me I'm I'm just get on with it and and
sort of acknowledge it I've learnt to
process it from a young age so when I'm
Powys to die on tall you know you almost
expected someone not to come home so you
price half process there anyway you just
make sure you give them a good send-off
and make sure the family are okay and
then crack on to the next task what's
the most dangerous thing you've ever
done
the most dangerous thing I have ever
done is going into combat but the most
safest thing I've ever done is is
strange because when I done Everest
that's the most dangerous thing I done
when I got caught on the summit in a
storm and I was at Hillary step with
five hours in a whiteout being
completely out of my control
it was definitely Everest but when it
comes to exposure to to danger
definitely be my tours of Afghanistan
you know kicking doors down when you've
got enemy of the other side and you in
control you know you've got your weapon
you've got the boys behind you you're
the aggressor it's a different type of
control what would you like to achieve
in the future you know I always have
some about ten other things in the
pipeline if you haven't got something to
look forward dry fall then you're dead
you're done you know forget it you know
the old adage or the old
wonderful quote browning and man's reach
should be beyond his grasp so there's a
few things in the future I still like to
do I did the venture as Grand Slam which
is climbing the highest mountain on each
continent and then north and south
geographical magnetic poles flown across
the Atlantic a couple times in a blue
and to the north pot one at blue and
what I'm finding now unfortunately the
minds willing the body slowing down mine
would be to go to the moon I'd love to
go out into space and people say to me
aren't you mad I'm not now I've done
every stunt on the the mutiny on the
bounty so I've done water I've done the
mountains I want to fire me into
spaceless yeah we go what advice would
you give you all younger self would I
change anything no what do I regret
anything no you know did I ever made
some bad life decisions absolutely I am
here the man I am today because of my
mistakes because of my failures because
of my successes I'm exactly where I'm
supposed to be right now
I wish I was more patient when I was
younger I always wanted it yesterday and
now I've got to that age where I don't
want groundwork and you can look back
and think I said to my son never this
and what you want to do when you grow up
says you want to be an adventurer like
Daddy he's 10 years old he went yeah but
I want a real job dad I'm gonna get
somebody to correct many years ago broke
3 min of course you normal injuries you
know black ice and always ever managed
to break my nose Donna why lost a couple
of teeth when I first started out men
were men and they fought fish the first
these days it's easy carrying a knife
he's gonna move the bowl is gonna smash
a glass on my face